so again choice this is an easy example
later on you'll see where you have to
dig a little bit further but
it's not impossible even if you get
something further
down the list which leads me to my
second reason why integration by parts
is not called reverse product rule
it's not just a rule but you apply them
blindly it's not just products
not just products
what i mean this integral here the
integrand is fairly obviously something
times something else it's like well use
integration by parts right
other things don't look like products
but
you can write them as products and then
use
integration by parts you might say why
do that and the answer is
when you have literally no other
alternatives so
feast your eyes on this
now we were first introduced to
um you know different integrals and
integrals and we used to think of
definite integrals as like integrals but
more work you say that again
we used to think of definite integrals
as like indefinite integrals with an
extra step it's like do the indefinite
integral
pop your numbers in do the evaluation
and off you go okay
in a case like this actually a definite
integral
would probably have been dramatically
easier can you tell me why
the indefinite integral is harder than
an equivalent like say i don't know
something like am i getting this right
hmm yeah something like that would be
fine
right this would actually be a trivially
easily easy question to do
extension one you could do this question
without any integration by parts what
would you do
yes give me a little more detail what
would you do with respect to
y yeah fantastic this thing's going to
give you an area
yeah if you have to think about what
sine inverse looks like
think about what the graph is right like
so
okay you're like oh this part down here
it's easy to work out by contrast
with um as you said just to go to the
other axis right
but i haven't given you that have i i've
given you this so we need to find a
primitive
of some kind now i gave you this clue i
said even though it doesn't look like a
product
we can write it as a product and then
use all of this knowledge
we already have so i'm gonna hand you
this
let's integrate not just sign inverse
but one
times sign inverse look ma it's a
product
you have to now make a choice you can
link about your detail acronym here
which might be an easier thing to choose
for dv
it's not that hard a choice recognizing
that if you chose this to be dv
you've just recreated the same problem
you started with right so let's choose
the other one to be dv it's
i guess it's algebraic sort of so i'm
going to call this u
this dv and then let's see what we get
i'll give you a minute or two's head
start
so somewhat like before
i'm so content that you can take this
from here then i'm not even going to
finish this but
just want to make sure you're headed in
the right direction here is me choosing
my u
and my dv which we already briefly
discussed here is me putting in my uv
minus integral of v d u when you have a
look at your integral v
d u tell me what you noticed think back
like a week to when we did integrating
when you've got
quadratic denominators what do you see
what do you see everything
say it again thank you reverse training
looks great to me right you've got
this thing in here which has its
derivative
or almost its derivative just up here in
the numerator
right so this is going to be something
like an f dash on f
situation and so you're good to go you
can use your reverse chain rule here and
i'm pretty content you'll get that
that's not the main focus for today
so why isn't it called uh reverse
product rule answer
it's not just a rule you blindly apply
you need to think and make some choices
and secondly it's not just for products
so i guess in summary you could say
and don't don't ask me how long i spent
taking this making this it was just
i just couldn't help myself okay now i
have one
last example to have a look at and it
doesn't really fit under either these
categories of um
i better put that away otherwise you'll
not concentrate right um
it doesn't fit under these categories of
why integration by parts is
called integration by parts um but it's
a what's what i'm looking for
it's gonna lead us into what we're
having a look at next
lesson so can you write this third
example with me
please we're going to form the integral
or calculate integral
of e to the x sine x
all right so
just like before i'd like you to help me
think right use your detail acronym
right which is the best choice here for
dv
it's right at the top of the list right
look you've got an exponential here okay
so i'm going to choose this
as dv choose that as u
makes sense okay let's have a quick go
so if i get u
being sine x someone tell me what d u is
it's cos x thank you if i made
e to the x dv then v is going to be
e to the x fantastic so things are all
marching along
just nicely you then start to say well
okay i'm going to say that equals 2
okay i've got my uv so there's u
v like so and then i'm going to subtract
i got enough space just i think
the integral of v d u
at which point you say
what have i done here okay now believe
it or not i've made progress even though
it doesn't look
like i have usually when we try and like
massage problems we hope that they will
get better
as we progress but it looks like i've
created a problem here
which is of a very similar level of
challenge
to the problem i started with do you
agree it's like uh
haven't improved this much okay don't
lose hope
stay with me if you got presented with
this as a question
in and of itself what would you do you'd
do it by parts right so let's have a go
again the challenge
uh sorry about the choice of which is
you on which is dv is not that
complicated i'm going to call
this u and this dv much like i did
before
i'm not even going to write rv and dv
again because i already did them
in blue over there i'm just going to say
if this u
equals cos x then my
d u on dx in this case will be just be
careful
we'll chat for the plus or minus what am
i going to get
then you sign x right okay so now i'm
going to
once more with feeling okay i've got
this e to the x
sine x hanging out the front and then i
subtract and then here comes
another integration of my parts
this u this v here someone just sorry
okay well done
so here comes the new u and the new v
is that okay uv bam here comes the new
v d u and something interesting has
happened right
here's v and then here's
d u
hold on a second
now you do have to be careful because
there's counter not one not two there's
three negatives there so very easy to
get wrong
one two three they're all being
multiplied but look at this
this is actually what we started with
sort of right there's an e to the x
sine x being integrated there so we're
going to pull the trick here which
wouldn't have made sense if i did it
right at the start but now you can see
why i'm about to do it
this original integral i'm going to give
it a name
it's an integral i've used the letter i
for something else in maths before so
that was the lowercase i
i'm going to call this capital i for
integral
okay this same integral appears right
here so i can do a bit of substitution
here
this whole thing is capital i right just
be really careful with your signs like i
said
e to the x sine x this here there's just
one minus sign
e to the x cos x you're okay with that
and then
one two three so i think i get
minus e d x sine
x but i already know what that is
that's i right so therefore
i'm going to substitute this
for this which is what i defined it to
be at the beginning so this gives me
eyes over here i might as well
factorizing while i'm at it just because
i like to
make things nice and tidy and i'm also
lazy about writing another e to the x
and then i've got a minus i here right
so now remembering that the whole goal
here was wanting to find out what i
is i'm just going to add a 9 to both
sides that gives me 2 over here
and all i need to do now is divide
through
by 2. does that make sense so
i'm just going to do it here
that's how lazy i am okay with that all
right good saving
savings that's right that's right i'm
being i'm being very sustainable
right 100 okay as long as you show me do
it okay
uh thank you i did do my final ah so
close
um i did do my final integration really
from
here actually uh because because at this
point it's still defined as
an indefinite integral does that make
sense and then here once i'm like oh
they're all gone now i have an actual
value or expression function for i
i should definitely like angular says
include my constant integration
make sense